hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast solutions beyond water I am
Judy Aurora black roots and alter your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by eppendorf eppendorf is a
leading life science company that
develops and sells instruments
consumables and services for liquid
sample and fill handling in laboratories
worldwide for more information please
visit eppendorf com we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the events you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speakers dr. honey
de henkaa and dr. Rudolph volchok dr.
henkaa is a field application specialist
focusing on liquid handling specialize
in positive displacement dispenser and
pipettes at eppendorf headquarters in
Hamburg Germany she joined eppendorf in
2015 after finishing her PhD in medical
microbiology on the topic of
staphylococcus epidermidis hip joint
infections at the University Hospital
and Hamburg in vitro microfiche studies
were part of her PhD research qty
focused on molecular biology and
genetics early during her studies of
biology at the University of Hamburg and
deepened her knowledge include
microbiology laboratories and a Harvard
Medical School in the group of professor
Roberto Coulter a project management
course in cooperation with johnson &
johnson medical in germany extended dr.
Henkes skills and establishing training
and giving seminars a musical education
by over to her studies in biology
brought her presentation skills to
perfection dr. Wilcox role is as the
global product manager in the area that
cell handling and liquid handling at
eppendorf VG he is located in Hamburg
Germany he studied biochemistry at the
University of true vegan and at the
Rockefeller University in New York
rudolph's PhD work at mo Heidelberg was
to investigate the mechanisms of
postmitotic nuclear pore complex
formation using protein biochemistry
molecular biology and cell biology
methods prior to joining eppendorf he
worked as a consultant for vcg focusing
on projects in healthcare industry I
will now turn it over to Rudolph and
honey to start the presentation so thank
you Judy and for your kind introduction
and good morning good afternoon and good
evening everyone and welcome to our
webinar solutions beyond water
successfully pipetting problematic
liquid my name is Rudolph ah Jack and
together with my colleague Hannah anchor
I will guide you through the webinar and
at the end of course we will also have a
Q&A session so what our objectives for
today's webinar and in the beginning we
want to provide you an overview of the
available different and tools and
instruments in working with liquids and
we want to highlight challenges that you
might be facing when working with
difficult or problematic liquids such as
volatile liquids like ethanol or viscous
liquids like glycerol we will introduce
the different problematic liquid classes
and at the same time of course present
solutions how to work with them and how
to handle them successfully and since we
will be pointing out a number of
benefits for a specific type of liquid
handling instruments namely dispensers
we also want to give you some brief
additional information on the benefits
that these dispensers have beyond
problematic liquids
so these are the chapters for today I
will start with the introduction and
then iono a will take you through the
different liquid challenges and liquid
classes so working in in life science
research almost everyone is somehow
handling liquids I mean this is no
surprise of course most of life's
processes occur in an aqueous amir and
consequently biochemists molecular
biologists and also cell biologists work
with aqueous solutions and here in this
tag cloud we've listed some of the most
typical applications and that you could
be using in your own research and they
all involve working with one kind or
another of liquid and probably you will
recognize two or three of these
applications that you are also facing in
your daily work and using and each of
these applications of course has
different liquids and depending on the
properties that these liquids have they
also have different requirements both in
terms of how you handle them but also in
terms of the knowledge you need for
working with them and also in terms of
the instruments and the tools that you
do that you use and we want to also shed
some light on this so usually we don't
think very thoroughly about the
different aspects that one might
consider when working with different
liquids but we want to give some brief
introduction on this as well so of
course the most important consideration
is what kind of liquids do you actually
work with so whether you have a glycerol
solution or for example and sulfuric
acid or a volatile solution and they can
be very different the way you have to
pipette them and work with them but the
kind of liquid is by far not the only
consideration that you have to have to
make another one of course is what's
your sample throughput how much
pipetting do you actually do how many
samples do you have and how many
pipetting steps do you do and also how
complex is the liquid handling work that
you do
additional aspects to consider are for
example in which volume range do you
work I'm typically microliter of course
in the life sciences and also other
things like what is your source and what
is your destination vessels or from
which bottle of vessel I am pipetting
into what target vessel and there are
many other things to consider and all
this depending on the individual
application in workflow determines the
optimal choice of your liquid handling
tool and we want to highlight the first
two categories or aspects a little more
before going into the different liquid
classes so if you think about the kind
of liquid that you work with we've made
a very simple gradient you see on the
left side there are some liquids which
are rather simple in terms of the
demands they make on the instrument on
the experiment later and some are more
demanding and what do we mean by this so
this is very much correlated with the
liquid with the properties of the
different liquids simple liquids are
those that have a low viscosity low
vapor pressure they do not contain
detergents or very low concentrations of
detergents and they are basically salt
solutions or simple aqueous solutions
more demanding liquids would be those
with a higher density high protein
concentration high viscosity vapor
pressure or for example hydrogen
concentration what are examples of these
liquids so of course most liquids in
life science being being used and being
worked with our aqueous solutions so
simple solutions could be saline
solution and even a low detergent
concentration containing solutions like
Oh point one percent SDS or a Triton
solution if you go to a cell culture
medium I'm containing fetal calf serum
or to a high concentration protein
solution you can already get film
formation and these are what we think
are more demanding solutions of course
if you go to liquids like blood or high
concentrations of glycerol and also PCR
master mix
these become more demanding and in
addition of course you have non equus
solutions or organic solvents like
acetone ethanol or mineral oil and these
are much more difficult in terms of how
to handle them how to pipette them and
the same is true for them solutions like
phosphoric acid and sulfuric acid so
this is our first aspect to consider the
other one is the throughput dimension so
the question how many samples how many
are petting steps do you actually have
and here we again have made a very
simple axis from low throughput to high
throughput which you see at the bottom
and on the left side it's the regular
simple standard pipetting and you you
work with individual tubes you do single
liquid transfers whereas the further you
move to the right side the more you will
be doing more tedious and fast complex
pipetting protocols and you will also be
working with vessels like plates and you
will have many samples and if you put
these two together we get what we call
the liquid handling matrix so the
different liquid handling tools like
different pipettes and also dispensers
are in different positions in this
matrix depending on the kind of liquid
you work with and on the sample
throughput or the number of pipetting
steps you do and we briefly want to
guide you through this so the first and
most well-known category of liquid
handling tools are manual pipettes these
are the standard air cushion pipettes
which are used by almost every life
science researcher and they are mostly
being used for routine pipetting tasks
they exist as single or multi channel
pipettes and something that you can do
if you work with more demanding liquids
if you go further up along the y-axis
you can use special tips or special
liquid and also special and pipetting
techniques and we will go into this in
the second part so special tips could be
for example dual filter tips as in a
those you could use for warm or
infectious liquids both to avoid
contamination but also
corrosion of your pipette and be as an
example of a low retention tip which
basically can be used for forming
liquids such as deterrent detergent
containing solutions if we go to higher
throughput now we're moving to the right
on the x-axis you see that an electronic
pipettes other tool of choice you can
more easily do higher throughput they
also exist as single or multi channel
pipettes of course on the left side you
see the pipette controller which is very
typical for cell culture work and also
of course electronic pipettes can be
used with different consumables like
special tips and of course you can
similarly apply a special pipetting
techniques if you go to even higher
throughput then you start entering the
realm of automated liquid handling and
this is for even higher throughput for
example if you want to feel complete
plates within one step so this is the
instrument on the left side which is the
EP motion 96 and if you want to go to
full automation both of pipetting and
also of incubating tasks then you can go
to use a pipetting robot which you see
on the right side which is the EP motion
for example and all these different
tools are actually in the in the area of
rather simple liquids so if you go to
very demanding liquids then we actually
recommend yet another tool and so these
are the handheld dispensers and those
are good for both doing long distancing
syria's if you want to distribute liquid
for example within a plate but also they
are very good for handling problematic
liquids and this is the focus for
today's presentation not so much on
these tools but actually on the kind of
work that you will be doing with them so
you see this is just giving you an
overview these are the first things to
consider and there are many different
choices for the right liquid handling
tool and the important thing here is if
you put some thought into what is the
best tool
your work of course working with liquids
will be easier for you it will be safer
and of course also you will have more
safety in terms of the quality of the
results that you that you get in the end
so throughout this webinar we will have
a number of different poor questions and
we would kindly ask you to to answer
these questions so this is our first
question and the question is which
liquid handling tools are you using in
your work so i will read this out loud
twice and we would kindly ask you to
answer the question so which liquid
handling tools are you using manual
pipettes or manual and electronic
pipettes many old pipettes and handheld
dispensers or all three manual
electronic pipettes and tender
dispensers or if you use a pipetting
robot please click on the last option
okay so I think we have the result
coming up okay so thank you very much
for for answering this question and this
is a very interesting result of course
and almost everyone is using manual
pipettes which includes the basically
the first four answers but it's very
nice to see that thirty percent are
already using electronic pipettes and
17.6 percent using dispensers so of
course today's talk will also highlight
some of the benefits of these tools so
maybe in the future you might consider
actually even using those tools also in
your work and now to go further I will
hand over to Hana a who will guide you
through the next part of the webinar
thank you very much Rudolph for this
nice introduction we will know now go
into the two main type of incest systems
that are available on the market
nowadays so as Rudolph already said
manual type ads with the air cushion
system are the most known pipettes so
these are many of the classic pipettes
therefore one attaches a tip onto a pipe
as you see they're inside the pipette is
a piston that you can see here in the
middle picture in the blue circle this
distant pushes out the air that is
naturally inside the pipette cone and
when you then ignores the tip into the
liquid the liquid is aspirated into the
tip due to the partial vacuum so what
you see on the far right picture this
red line indicates the air inside of a
hat and the Blue Drop indicates the
liquid that has been aspirated so the
second system is called positive
displacement system and it's mainly used
for dispenser systems so with this
system you have a tip that has an
integrated piston inside the tip as
indicated by the arrow on the far right
this distance pulled upwards while
handling the dispenser and the liquid is
soaked into the tip directly so as you
see in the picture there is no air in
between the sample and the piston this
system has distinct advantages compared
to an air cushion pipette so keep the
positive displacement system in mind
during the webinar but first of all let
us have a look on pipetting techniques
using the classic air cushion pipettes
each of the following techniques can be
used in certain cases also when it comes
to problematic liquids the most common
technique is called forward pipetting
and i bet all of you are doing this
already so one presses to the first stop
of the operation button then immerses
the tip into the liquid and releases the
button again so the liquid is soaked
into the tip to release the liquid and
to perform the blowout it is mandatory
to push the operation button down to the
second stop with this technique it is
necessary to perform the blowout
otherwise the liquid volume is not
accurate so as you see on the picture in
far right no liquid is left inside the
tip now we compared to another technique
that is called reverse pipetting this is
the second technique applicable with air
cushion pipettes so you start by pushing
the operation but
to the second stop then emerged the tip
into the liquid and aspirate the liquid
you will now aspirate your desired
liquid volume + D blowout volume and to
release the liquid you push the
operation button to the first stop and
to spend your liquid as you see on the
picture on the right and circled in
green they will always be arrest inside
the tip that has to be discarded this is
the actual blowout volume you will not
be using this technique can be used for
some problematical eclipse for example
glycerol air cotton pipettes in general
are developed for the usage would equate
solutions like water common both of like
tryst and saline solutions so all air
cushion pipettes are calibrated using
distilled water at room temperature the
liquids with properties similar to water
can be transferred accurate but what
happens if you are using a solution
different than water and this is the
actual topic of the whole webinar so for
example 1 preparing competent cells or
stuck cultures glycerol is necessary the
classic DNA extraction requires for
nolan chloroform these solutions may
drip out of the pipette tip for blobs a
tween 20 containing buffer is necessary
and the detergent may remain inside the
pipette tip in cell culture medium is a
high protein content that leads to film
formation and the warm medium itself
bears the risk of aerosol formation a
PCR setup contains multiple different
solutions so what you realize now is
that you are actually using problematic
liquids every day they all have
different properties then water here
will show some typical problems you face
when handling problematic liquids like
leftovers in the tip on the upper left
corner contaminations as in cell culture
on the upper right corner corner in this
case the cells are contaminated with
bacteria and we have an inaccurate
volume delivery and erratic differences
in positive performance which you see in
the two bottom pictures like you don't
have duvall
you actually set on your pipette or if
your packaging glycerol even when using
different techniques you hardly get the
exact amount of volume that you desire
so all these challenges can be overcome
using the right tools and the right
technique now I would like to have a
look on the pipetting solutions for each
liquid class today we will discuss six
main classes number one will be volatile
liquids that tend to drip out of the
pipette tip the second will be viscous
liquids which are difficult to aspirate
and have a bad flow behavior the third
topic will be liquids which are colder
than room temperature like directly out
of the fridge or the freezer then we
will go over to liquids warmer than room
temperature like cell culture medium
then I will lead you through liquids
with a higher density than water and the
last liquid will be foaming liquids that
contain a lot of protein or detergents
the web let us start with volatile
liquids and another poll question so how
do you type it ethanol please choose one
of the answers number one would be as
fast as possible to avoid dripping I
just decanted I use reverse pipetting or
I type it ethanol by mouth so please
choose your answer on how your pipetting
ethanol we're waiting for a few seconds
until everyone made a choice and then we
will discuss the results and go over to
volatile liquids so the time is over now
we will see the results soon great so
most of you thank you for your answers
most of your answer that you simply
hurry up when transferring ethanol I
know this answer and I did it myself
during my studies so but now let's have
a look on some easier and safer options
volatile liquids are for example ethanol
Joan and chloroform these liquids have a
high vapor pressure that leads to an
expansion of the air cushion and
dripping out of the pipette tip in
combination with an air cushion pipette
if you see in the picture where the
little drop forms at the end of the tip
this automatically leads to liquid loss
and possible contamination or even a
health risk when drops are spread over
the workbench so additionally the liquid
can evaporate into the pipe and cone and
lead to damages inside the five hat when
using an air cushion pipette with a
volatile liquid you should pre wet the
tip 2 to 3 times and perform reverse
pipetting technique some of you already
answered that you're reducing reverse
type heading in the last poll question
so this is very good actually so these
two tips may help avoiding the dripping
but it strongly depends on the
concentration of the liquid if these
recommendations work properly for
example when pipetting seventy percent
ethanol two times preventing is
sufficient to avoid the dripping but
with ninety-six percent ethanol you
would need three times pre-wedding it is
safer and more convenient to you the
dispenser with the positive displacement
system because the absence of the air
and the enclosed sample inside the tip
no drops can leak out of the tip so what
you see in the right picture is that the
ethanol in that case it's orange is
soaked into the dispenser tip and there
is no air between the piston and the tip
so there's no failure and no leaking no
dripping so before we come to the next
chapter I would like to ask another poll
question so how do you pipe it how many
like viscous liquids like life the role
there are four choices to do oh I cut
the tip I use reverse pipetting I leave
the tip inside the liquid for a long
time until I think it has aspirated the
correct volume or I use a scale to
determine the amount of glycerol
so please make your decision now on how
you pipe out honey light viscous liquids
like 90 just a few more seconds I'm
really looking forward to the answers
here we go okay so forty percent most of
you just leave the tip inside the liquid
for a long time until you think it has
aspirated to correct volume yeah I can
definitely understand it because it
flows that slowly and then some of you
are cutting the tip and some of you are
using reverse pipetting which is really
good and there's just like thirty
percent using a scale to determine the
amount of glycerol so for those of you
who are cutting the tip I did it myself
during my studies but and I know it's
frequently done but it's actually the
worst you can do because then you won't
have an accurate volume delivery anymore
as soon as the tip is cut you or no
manufacturer could guarantee that the
volume deliveries accurate so let us see
what exactly happens when pipetting
glycerol as i mentioned example for
honey like or viscous liquids are
glycerol with the concentration above
fifty percent blood skin cream or
mineral oil this coupe liquids have a
high in a friction between molecules in
the liquid and increased pressure is
necessary to transfer the liquid
appropriately these liquids show bad
flow behavior and the risk of aspiration
air bubble is quite high so accurate
volume delivery is almost impossible
with air cushion pipettes since you will
always have left overs and sorry inside
the tip but what you see here on the
picture there is a left over of glycerol
inside the tip so this chart shows the
comparison of an air cushion pipette
using forward pipetting with the brown
line and reverse pipetting which is the
green line and comparing you to using a
dispenser with
positive displacement system which is
the blue line it is obvious that the
desired volume of 50 micro liter is not
accurately achieved by a crash and
perhaps no matter which technique is
used so for those of you who are using
reverse pipetting this is actually more
accurate than forward pipetting so this
is pretty good but the only system that
gives reliable results is a positive
displacement system so even if you
execute a low aspiration and low
disbanding speed as well as reverse
pipetting when using an air cushion
pipette you will never have as accurate
results as with a positive displacement
system additionally the piston inside
the positive displacement tip of the
dispenser wipes the tip clean on the
inside to avoid leftovers and to
guarantee a full volume delivery so you
don't have any sample loss furthermore
you can work faster when using a
positive displacement system with
viscous liquids because it has a higher
force oh now we will jump over to the
third liquid class which are cold
liquids these are very often used in the
lab cold means in this case that the
liquid has a temperature below room
temperature and often these liquids are
used directly out of the freezer like
enzymatic solution that minus 20 degrees
or directly out of the fridge like yeast
medium at 428 degrees the cold liquids
lead in the first pipetting step to a
shrinking of the warmer air cushion
inside the pipette and with this to a
higher volume delivery and set if you
are using the same tip for multiple
pipetting steps the air cushion expands
again and then less volume is delivered
than set so after all you're positing
rod result is always inaccurate with an
air cushion bypass you should always let
you liquid equilibria to room
temperature before using it with an air
Cashin pipette but this can be a problem
especially for enzymes and should be
avoided as I think all of you know
they don't like to get warm so
additionally you can perform reverse
pipetting to receive a more accurate
result but the best solution is a system
with without any air cushion like a
descender or like a positive
displacement system so it is independent
of the temperature of the liquid and
delivers the x accurate volume because
there is simply no air cushion that can
shrink or expand for the next liquid
cloth which are warm and or infectious
liquids that has a temperature higher
than room temperature for example cell
culture medium at 37 degrees these warm
liquids have multiple risk factors so
we'll start with the first one first of
all the warm liquid leads to a shrinking
of the air cushion in the first
pipetting step and leads to higher
volume delivered and set again and in
all following pipetting steps with the
same tip the air cushion gets smaller
again because it is still cold it's
still colder than the liquid used so the
air inside the pipette is still colder
than the liquid you try to transfer
therefore the volume delivery is higher
than that so you're pirating result
again is inaccurate additionally and
that's the highest risk you face a very
high risk of evaporation of the liquid
into the inside of the air cushion
pipette and with this to contamination
via air results so I would like to go
more into detail on aerosoles because
these are high thread nowadays our goals
are tiny liquid drops that evaporate
basically always from the liquid into
the pipette tip and with this directly
into the pipe at cone as you see on the
picture on the right especially warm
liquids lead to very high a result
formation these ella rose may constantly
contaminate your pipette and with this
cross contaminate all samples that your
pipe fitting afterwards additionally you
will face a false volume delivery and
may risk corrosion or d'bries inside
hi Pat cone so what can you do to avoid
these aerosol formations some general
recommendations to avoid a result
formation even in your sample tube a
mixing of the sample by rolling the tube
rather than shaking then you should
pipette directly into a liquid or onto a
surface to avoid bubbling and splashing
placing your sample tubes close to each
other diminishes the way you need to
pass when transferring liquids and keep
in mind to slowly remove caps or
stoppers to avoid a sudden opening of a
tube and again splashes so during
positing regarding the transfer of
liquid using an air cushion pipette you
may use the filter tip to avoid splashes
and retain our results as well as large
biomolecules like DNA and RNA also
bacteria and viruses are held back by a
filter tip so in the picture you see a
one-layer filter but the best is
actually to use a two-layered filter so
it guarantees the highest security when
using an air cushion pipette these two
layered filters have different pore
sizes to avoid a result going through
these filters so as an e-version safer
option a positive displacement systems
recommended since here the sample is
enclosed inside the tip completely you
can see on the picture that the sealing
lip of the tip tightly encloses the
sample and the space in between the
sample and the instrument is protected
against arizona's exaggerated what we
talked about so no air cushion no
aerosols at all so let us go over to the
fifth liquid class the dense liquid ends
liquids have a higher density relative
to water examples are South auric and
phosphoric acid or caesium chloride
solution the heavy weight of the liquid
leads to an elongation of the air Kush
and with this to less volume delivered
and set so again the volume delivery is
not accurate with air caching perhaps
this graph shows the deviation between
the volume delivery of liquid food at
differing density than water for example
ethanol is not only volatile but has
also a lower density than water and
leads to a higher volume delivery then
set when packaging additionally it drips
out of the piper tip as we discussed
earlier a high density liquid like South
Park effort leads to less volume
delivered and set as you can see here
almost one percent left and set so if
your pipe adding 100 micro litre and you
have one percent less delivered then you
would only have 99 purse 99 microliter
and especially with with acids this can
all already lead to a high deviation in
your experiment and because it's a high
deviation of concentration to have lost
almost one microliter so with air
curtain pipettes you only have one
option you have to adjust the prepare to
the high density liquid which means that
this pipette can only be used for the
liquid adjusted to some users are also
weighing the liquid so for example if
you want to pipe at 50 micro litre of
sulfuric acid the users are weighing out
the liquid to know which volume to set
on the pipette if we set it extreme if
you want to pipe at 50 milliliter you
would have to set 60 math later on the
pipette but this way to do it is
actually not accurate and user
adjustment according to the user menu
would be the safer option but not all
manufacturers give this opportunity so I
could just give you one one
recommendation will for eppendorf we
offer pipettes with a user adjustment so
you just look up in the user menu that
you want to pipe itself work effort and
then you can easily turn the pipette to
+1 on a little window you can see it on
pictures of the pipette and then you can
easily pipe at the dense liquid and you
can turn it back to zero and then go on
with water so this is very convenient so
but if you don't have a pipette that is
adjustable the easiest and most
convenient way to transfer high density
liquids is the usage of a dispenser with
the positive displacement system no
adjustment is necessary and one can
transfer the high density liquid
accurate and precise another advantage
is the safety of the system especially
when using aggressive efforts since the
sample is securely enclosed in the
dispenser typical so this is safe for
your pipette for your workbench and for
yourself now let's come to another poll
question how do you deal with foaming or
detergent containing liquid this will be
the last class we will discuss so you
have four different answers I use your
birth pipetting I use a step or Peter or
dispenser I just accept the phone or i
reactivate the form or the bubbles from
the liquid to get rid of them so please
make your decision we will wait a few
seconds so the answer will be coming
soon okay here we go most of you are
using the reverse type has reversed
pipetting that's very very good some of
you are also using a step or Peter or
dispenser which is also great thank you
for already using the device some of you
just accept the phone and some of you re
aspirate the phone in the bubbles so I
would like to give some recommendation
for the ones who accept the foam or we
aspirate the form so you don't have to
do this you can have your experiments
more precisely without the phone
but first of all let's have a look on
the liquid class of foaming liquids
foaming can be a result of different
liquids for example high protein content
liquids like vs a solution or cell
culture medium and also detergent
containing liquids like bottles
containing tween-20 or Crichton x100
performing a blowout with air cushion
pipettes with these liquids leads to
bubbles and foam formation the ascending
foam can lead to a contamination and
cross contamination of the pipette and
other samples so actually having the
foam inside your Piper tip is a very
high risk again also of aerosol
formation additionally detergents stick
to the tip wall as indicated with blue
dyes detergent in this picture this
leads to less wall in the degree than
the set volume and again inaccurate
results so this graph visualizes the
residual moisture of detergents in a
standard paper tip after pipetting with
an air cushion pipette the violet bars
show the residual moisture in the
standard tip while the pink bars show
the residual moisture when using a tip
developed for detergent containing
liquid called low retention tip the most
alarming residual moisture when positing
PCR master mix with a standard tip shows
that almost 6 micro litre of the master
mix rest inside the piper tip invisible
stuck to the tip wall because as you all
know PCR master mix is colorless when
using a low retention to pipe a tip not
even one microliter of the detergent
containing PCM our stomachs rest inside
the tip so the yield is much higher the
volume delivery is more accurate your
results will be more reliable and use a
free agents so the first trick when
using an air cushion pad pad for
detergent liquids is to use low
retention tips which has been specially
developed for this application a second
option is to perform reverse pipetting
with standard
but again there will still be detergent
back to the tip wall the best option
would be to use a positive displacement
system you avoid the bubbles and the
phone and additionally wipe the inside
of the tip with the sealing lip to avoid
residues and guarantee accurate volume
delivery so now we've been through with
the liquid classes and the corresponding
solution and I will hand over back to
Rudolf who will go through some
additional benefit of defender systems
so thanks on a so as you've seen when
going through the different liquid
classes we've highlighted and dispensers
as a tool or the tool of choice which is
applicable for most of the problematic
liquids and dispensers have additional
benefits when you work with liquids also
for for normal not so demanding simple
liquids and we briefly want to highlight
those as well so these pendants can help
to speed up and fill its ability to your
work these are examples that almost
everyone of you may be familiar with so
one is filling plates with medium or
buffer so the dispenser allows you to
briefly go from well too well and to
fill all the different worlds without
having to aspirate the liquid multiple
times so you work much faster and the
same is true and is depicted in the
middle if for example you are doing an
essay where you have short time points
and you have to add reagents or other
agents to your liquid and you have to do
it in a very fast way so also here the
the dispenser is really very beneficial
for your work another very typical
application highlighted on the right
side is when you are ellicott
incompetent bacterial cells of course
here you are working on eyes and you
have to be very fast as well to preserve
the competence of the bacteria so this
pendous can help you to work in a fast
way they are simple they are stress-free
and the nice thing is that they are
really
good tool for working with all sorts of
different liquids and liquid classes so
this is true for both manual and
electronic instruments and we have one
slide on which we also want to highlight
the additional benefits that come with
using electronic dispensers so on the
left side you see the multi pet III X
this is a dispenser that eppendorf
offers and there are very different
programs that you can choose and they
allow you to do many other things with
liquids to test different liquid
handling applications and we just
briefly want to highlight what those are
so you can use electronic dispensers for
doing ph adjustment and so you can very
easily titrate buffers for example there
is a new function which is called s
parade and dispense where you can take
up in an unknown sample volume from for
example different tubes and then you can
dispense it in different volumes that
you can actually set so this is very
convenient and you don't have to for
example pool ill awaits them in a tube
before you actually go to your next
dispensing step then of course you can s
/ 8 different volumes for example
supernatants so you can pool samples in
a very convenient way the way the system
works is also that mixing the the
different samples in the tip is also
very convenient by just swinging the tip
and of course another possibility which
is the fourth one highlighted here is if
you are doing a dilution series and you
are doing sequential dispensing you can
program your electronic dispenser and
can very easily conduct a dilution
series you can also use the electronic
to Spencer like a regular pipette so
there's a pipette function and of course
you can also do automatic dispensing
where you just set the different volumes
you want to use and you set the time
intervals and you don't have to press
every time you want
Spence your liquid so these are just
some examples we want to highlight to
you that using an electronic dispenser
combines both the advantages of
successfully handling problematic
liquids with the many different
applications that have become accessible
when using an electronic pipette /
dispenser and at the same time using it
is really easy and it really helped you
can help your work to become much faster
and much easier so towards the end I
will hand over to hun I again who will
very briefly summarize both the lessons
learned and today during the webinar and
also present you in overview what is the
recommended technique or tool for the
different liquid classes thank you very
much Rudolf for introducing the
electronic defenders let us sum up what
we just heard to this webinar so I'd
like to go through some key points we
just discussed the first one as we learn
about is choosing the right liquid
handing tool is critical and essential
for optimal experimental results
additionally we heard that not all lick
without equal so problematic liquids
need special techniques and tools a
positive displacement system is suitable
for most problematic liquids and
electronic instruments offer a wealth of
additional functions and are easy to
handle so this slide gives you an
overview of the techniques to apply with
problematic liquids when using air
Cashin pipettes first of all volatile
liquids like ethanol should be
transferred applying reverse pipetting
after pre-wedding the pipette tip
viscous liquids may be transferred
applying reverse pipetting and a very
low speed with an air cushion pipette
for liquids with a different density
than water your only option is to adjust
the air cushion pipette and when
transferring detergent this can be
achieved by using special or retention
tips and reverse pipetting with the air
cushion pipettes last
be warm as well as infectious liquids
that could lead to errors of formation
and these may be transferred using two
layered filter tips with an air cushion
pipette as you realize now that no
matter which problem problematic liquid
your pipetting the usage of the
appropriate technique is essential
furthermore for any of the liquids we
talked about positive displacement
systems aren't ideal choice so here we
will have the last poll question for the
webinar this poll question will be left
open until they complete the total end
of this webinar so even after the Q&A
session so we would really like to know
from you how did you rate the content of
this webinar you may choose between very
good good okay and poor so I would like
to thank you very much for this
attention for your attention so far we
would also show you 31 seconds where you
could learn a bit more about liquid
handling when you like to so eppendorf
offers a webinar series this year
covering topics such as calibration of
pipettes pipetting in cell culture
pipette tip quality and automated liquid
handling so you may visit our liquid
handling webpage at WWF norcom and if
you want to learn more about the
dispensers you could go to eppendorf
calm / multipad minus system if you
would like to take a look an eppendorf
liquid handling products you also may
visit us on our boots on an exhibition
for example the analytica in Munich in
Germany or in Shanghai China or in I
hope i pronounced it correctly hyderabad
in india and for participating in a
pipette clinic or a full day training of
pipetting techniques you also may visit
our homepage and the event of training
center for further information or
contact your local local sales rep for a
demo or
opportunities so thank you very much for
your attention now we wish you to
successfully pop it your problematic
liquid and we're looking forward to
answer your questions thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green fluid a button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can our first question is does the tip
of a dispenser harm self in cell culture
um yes so second so um the question
world does the tip of a dispenser homme
cells in cell culture right so no
actually so far we don't have any
evidence for dispenser tip harming the
cells but since each cell line is
different I would recommend to start
with the viability of any of the cells
to be sure that the cell and you are
using can be handled with this system
yeah it is possible to wash and reuse
the dispenser kit so it is not
recommended to wash and reuse the tips
it might happen that small residue still
stick to the inside of the tip when
washing was not intense enough and when
putting the tips into a dishwasher while
the two components of a tip are
separated and accurate fitting of the
piston inside the tip cannot longer be
guaranteed and and so I think most of
you do not wash their normal piper tips
so you shouldn't do this with defender
tips as well and I autoclave the
dispenser tip no sorry since the piston
and the tip are made of two different
plastic pipes that behave different in
yo declare they would not longer fit
together after autoclaving so I always
have to dispense liquid in multiple
steps when using a dispenser actually
when you're working with
manual dispenser you do not have the
option to choose another dispensing
technique you always have to defend the
multiple steps but when you're using an
electronic dispenser you might also have
the option to use it like a pipette for
example with the new multi Patrick Peter
III X he has a pipette mode and they can
just an ester it and dispense the same
volume what if I only want to pipette
only two microliters of a precious
viscous liquid okay so um I pattern
means that you would only aspirate to
microliter and want to defend it again
so therefore also positive displacement
type a success so these are actually no
descendant is a really positive
displacement type apps they work
according to the same principle like a
defender their tips have a piston inside
and in close the sample completely but
these positive displacement tips cannot
be used for dispensing only for
pipetting and they go down to very small
wall volumes for example one to twenty
microliters which would be the bio
master what's your variable volume
pipette turn into a fixed volume
high-tech after adjustment this is
actually a very complicated question to
get the accurate volume delivery of your
high density liquids you might need a
smaller air cushion inside the pipette
so that one microliter needs to be
aspirated additionally for example when
you test the volume of your pipette to
100 micro liter and then adjust it to
aspirate additionally one microliter you
must add this one microliter to all
other volumes to so for water you would
then Esper at 101 micro liter which is
not accurate but with the higher density
liquid you will a spurt 100 microliters
since the air cushion is adjusted to
this density so basically an adjusted
pipette can only be used for the one
liquid you adjusted it to and only with
the volume set that you use for a
so you could just if you have a 100 to
1,000 micropipette you adjusted at 100
mph Alito to attend liquids you can
really just use it as a 100 micro litre
pad pad for this dense liquid so it
doesn't make that much of a sense so I
would always recommend to use a positive
displacement system for that mean
explain pre-wedding the pipette is what
does that mean okay yeah I've said this
word quite a few times so this means
that you actually estimate the liquid
you want to transfer once into the tip
and release it directly back into the
same vessel so that the inside of the
tip is once in contact with the liquid
this leads to a saturation of the air
kush inside the positive and this raises
the accuracy of your packaging volume so
in the next step you would then after at
the volume desired again and transfer it
to your target vessel it's like an
additional type of thing step next
person thank you for your informative
webinar when we're getting viscous
liquid using air cushions pipettes does
it help if a higher volume pipette is
used for instance I pipette one
milliliter of tweens I think that's a
2.0 using a five milliliter pipette okay
that's an interesting question thank you
very much actually this even hires the
inner curacy of the pipette because the
bigger the air cushion is the worst is
the inaccuracies so if you have to use
an air cushion pad pad for transferring
glycerol you should use the pipette
according to the volume you want to
transfer so in this special case if you
want to pack at one milliliter of tween
20 then please use a 1 milliliter
pipette if you don't have any other
options and apply reverse pipetting you
have repeater III
with multiple channels actually we do
not have the repeater it reacts with
multiple channels but when using a
dispenser you can fill all these wells
and so men in multiple steps that
actually a multi-channel version is not
necessary because you can fill the tip
and dispense in 96 steps so you can
easily fill a whole plate and we did
some comparisons here with our
colleagues that using the repeater III X
compared to a multi-channel manual
pipette is much faster well thank you i
would like to once again shanked after
Henry Hank yet and dr. Rudolf will check
for their presentations do you have any
final comments oh thank you very much
for all your attention and your very
nice the moderator Judy yeah thanks a
lot also from my side it was very nice
and if you have any this goes to the
customers if you have any additional
questions about liquid handling please
approach eppendorf and we always prepare
to help you with your liquid handling
work thank you very much yes thank you
once again and have a nice day or a good
night depending on where you are in the
world thanks again for your
presentations and I would also like to
thank our sponsor eppendorf for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through October of
2016 you will receive an email from lab
roots alerting you in this webcast will
be available for replay we invite you to
afford that announcement your colleagues
you missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye I